[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis herzlich Willkommen an diesem
Samstagabend zwei wichtige Fußballspiele
heute im Sport mit Rudi zerner genau
zweimal Finale Champions League der
Frauen und DFB-Pokal Männer und auf
diese Themen schauen wir ausführlich
eine nationale Tragödie Indien erlebt
eines der schwersten Zugunglücke seit
Jahrzehnten mindestens 288 Menschen
sterben
Grenzen setzen china hat deutsche
Kampfpiloten angeworben
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius fordert
ein unverzüglichen Stopp
Enttäuschung und Hoffnung die Frauen vom
VfL Wolfsburg verlieren im Champions
League Finale im DFB-Pokalendspiel der
Männer trifft Leipzig auf Frankfurt
[Musik]
das Zugunglück in Indien ist verheerend
mindestens 288 Menschen sind ums Leben
gekommen rund 300 Menschen verletzt
worden in Deutschland werden dabei
Erinnerungen wach an das Zugunglück von
Eschede was ich vor genau 25 Jahren
ereignete auf das Gedenken in Eschede
schauen wir gleich beginnen die Sendung
mit dem Blick nach Indien
der Unfall ereignete sich gestern im
Osten des Landes rund 220 km von der
Millionenstadt culkata entfernt im
Bezirk balasso insgesamt verunglückten
drei Züge möglicherweise verursacht
durch menschliches Versagen mehr von
Jürgen Kehl
umgekippte Waggons liegen kreuz und quer
über hunderte Meter erstreckt sich am
Morgen das Bild der Katastrophe was ist
passiert der
schnellzug-express an Bord rund 1250
Passagiere ist auf einem falschen Gleis
unterwegs und kollidiert mit einem
stehenden Güterzug aus der Gegenrichtung
kracht Minuten später der Hofer super
fast Express besetzt mit mehr als 1000
Passagieren in die Unglücksstelle an
Albtraum gestern Abend Ortszeit 7 Uhr
ich war gerade eingeschlafen da kippte
der Zug um 10 bis 15 Menschen stürzten
auf mich drauf ich war ganz unten mein
armes verletzt und mein Nacken
ich kam gerade aus dem Waschraum als der
Zug plötzlich kippte ich habe das
Gleichgewicht verloren habe mich
irgendwo festgehalten meine Schuhe meine
Tasche alles Flo krumm ich habe gar
nicht verstanden was passiert
Rettungskräfte und Anwohner eilen herbei
helfen den Passagieren aus den Trümmern
schnell wird klar viele Verletzte sind
in der verkalten Waggons unter
tonnenschweren Stahl Schrott eingeklemmt
immer wieder kommt es in Indiens großen
Eisenbahnnetz zu Unglücken diese
Katastrophe mit zwei Schnellzügen wird
zur Chefsache Premierminister Modi eilt
zu den unglücksopfern zeigt so sein
Mitgefühl und verspricht auch
finanzielle Entschädigungen und
Aufklärung
die Regierung nimmt den Vorfall sehr
ernst wir haben eine genaue Untersuchung
angeordnet und wer immer schuldig sein
wird wird streng bestraft ohne Ausnahme
als Unfallursache wird menschliches
Versagen vermutet möglicherweise wurde
eine Weiche falsch gestellt
so bislang schwersten Zugunglück in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik ist es
heute vor genau 25 Jahren gekommen in
Esche der im gleich sein ICE und prallte
gegen eine Straßenbrücke 101 Menschen
starben mehr als 100 Menschen wurden
verletzt welche Konsequenzen die
Deutsche Bahn daraus gezogen hat und wie
an dem heutigen Tag der Opfer gedacht
wurde berichtet Oliver deutscher
Eschede 10:58 Uhr stilles Gedenken am
Mahnmal für zwei Stunden fahren die Züge
hier und heute mit starke drosselten
Tempo vorbei
Hinterbliebene Rettungskräfte Vertreter
der Bahn AG und Passagiere die im
Unglückszug saßen sind gekommen einer
von ihnen Udo Bauch seitdem
schwerbehindert arbeitsunfähig und mein
Leben wurde dadurch auch zerstört am 3
juni 1998 Leben ein ganz anderes Leben
wie vorher das Schmerzmittel natürlich
auch nach 25 Jahren ist das Schmerz von
vielen Verletzten Hinterbliebenen
Reitern auch und Helfern und angegriffen
immer sehr sehr große davon nie
vergessen
der dritte sechste 1998 mit Tempo 200
und rund 300 Menschen am Bord entgleiste
der aus München kommen die ICE breite
gegen eine Brücke die daraufhin
einstürzte und verursache war ein
gebrochener Rat Reifen am dritten Waggon
101 Menschen starben mehr als 100
Personen wurden verletzt teilweise
lebensgefährlich ich möchte gerne im
Namen des gesamten Vorstands der
Deutschen Bahn
unsere bitte um Entschuldigung und
unsere bitte um Verzeihung für das
entstandene menschliche Leid erneuern
die juristische Aufarbeitung des
Unglücks dauerte lange im Frühling 2003
stellte das Lüneburger Landgericht das
Verfahren gegen drei Ingenieure ein da
sie aus Sicht der Richter keine schwere
Schuld traf 25000 Mark zahlte die Bahn
pro Todesopfer nach dem Zugunglück
wurden Auflagen verschärft und mehr
Kontrollen angeordnet
nach Leipzig wo heute Abend eine große
Demonstration der linksautonomen Szene
stattfinden sollte Anlass war das Urteil
gegen die Studentin wegen Überfällen auf
rechtsextreme die Demo bleibt verboten
dennoch bereitet sich die Polizei auf
tausende Menschen vor bereits am
Nachmittag brannten mehrere Fahrzeuge im
Stadtteil Connewitz war es schon in der
Nacht zur Ausschreitungen gekommen dabei
wurden Barrikaden errichtet und
angezündet
und vor Ort ist für uns Thomas Bercht
Thomas
also die Lage ist nicht friedlich und
der Abend hat ja auch gerade erst
angefangen es war hier so dass es eine
protestdemo gegen dieses
Demonstrationsverbot gegeben hat sie war
auch genehmigt die Polizei liest aber
die Leute dann nicht laufen weil sie
sich geweitert hatten ihre Vermummungen
abzulegen es bebt bei einer stationären
Versammlung die die Polizei dann auch
abgesichert hat dementsprechend was die
Versammlungsteilnehmer als Provokation
empfunden hatten so reichte gegen 18 Uhr
vier ungefähr bis dahin hielt dieser
Burgfrieden ein einzelner Böllerwurf und
massiver Ausbruchsversuche auszulösen
auch begleitet von Angriffen gegen
Polizeiautos zur Stunde versuchen die
Beamten die Versammlungsteilnehmer aus
der Innenstadt heraus zu drängen
Richtung Leipzig Connewitz dass ich die
Sache aber innerhalb von ein zwei
Stunden jetzt wieder erledigt damit
rechnet ja eigentlich niemand
vielen Dank aus Leipzig
in die Ukraine dort zeigt sich Präsident
selenski zuversichtlich das Land sei
bereit für die lang erwartete
ukrainische Gegenoffensive sagte er dem
Wall Street Journal zudem kündigte
selenski die Überprüfung aller
Schutzbunker an zuvor hatten Bürgerinnen
und Bürger wegen der andauernden
russischen Luftangriffe kritisiert dass
es in Kiew zu wenige Bunker gebe und
diese teils verschlossen sein am
Donnerstag waren drei Menschen bei einem
Angriff getötet worden sie sollen vor
einem verschlossenen Bunker gestanden
haben
Chinas Machtanspruch im Indopazifik ist
das beherrschende Thema einer prominent
besetzten Sicherheitskonferenz in
Singapur
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin warnte
sein chinesischen Kollegen vor einer
militärischen Eskalation dort als
unfreundlichen Akt sieht der deutsche
Verteidigungsminister Pistorius auch
dass Chinas Militär expiloten der
Luftwaffe angeheuert hat aus Singapur
Thomas Reichert
TV Kameras dürfen nicht dabei sein aber
zumindest ein offenen Worten fehlt es
offenbar nicht das Boris Pistorius heute
mit Chinas Verteidigungsminister lichang
Fu zusammen trifft Recherchen von ZDF
und Spiegel zeigen dass Chinas Militär
ehemalige Piloten der Luftwaffe als
Trainer beschäftigt ich habe deutlich
gemacht dass ich erwarte dass diese
Praxis und vor uns unverzüglich beendet
wird und habe ihm klargemacht dass er
sicherlich nicht amüsiert wäre wenn ich
das meinerseits probieren würde Chinas
Verteidigungsminister habe Anwerbungen
Beschäftigung der Piloten nicht
bestritten so Pistorius besorgt sind
deutsche Geheimdienste insbesondere dass
die Piloten NATO Taktiken und Technik
verraten könnten das ist von
chinesischer Seite eindeutig ein
feindliches Verhalten ich erwarte dass
die Bundeswehr jetzt alle Maßnahmen
unternimmt und das zu unterbinden einer
der ehemaligen Bundeswehr Piloten beruft
sich darauf schon 2013 eine Trainer
Genehmigung erhalten das Ministerium wie
die Fälle prüfen möglicherweise gibt es
eine Gesetzeslücke man muss regeln
finden dass
ehemalige Piloten
durchaus
Flugschüler nehmen können aber nicht aus
Ländern mit denen wir eine strategische
Rivalität haben das Treffen von
sicherheitspolitikern in Singapurs
geprägt von der Gefahr einer
militärischen Auseinandersetzung
zwischen China und dem Westen die
gemeinsame Recherchen von ZDF und
Spiegel haben hier in Singapur
erhebliche diplomatische Aufregung
gesorgt china hat mit seiner Anwerbung
ehemaliger Luftwaffenpiloten aus
deutscher Sicht eine klare Linie
überschritten in seinem Machtanspruch
ein Erfahrung die viele andere
asiatische Länder mit China schon seit
Jahren machen
der türkische Präsident erdogan ist nach
seiner Wiederwahl offiziell in eine
dritte fünfjährige Amtszeit gestartet im
Parlamenten Ankara legte der 69-Jährige
den Amtszeit ab und erhielt seine
ernährungsurkunde
erdogan ist seit insgesamt 20 Jahren an
der Macht KritikerInnen werfen dem
islamisch konservativen Präsidenten vor
die Opposition zu unterdrücken am
Sonntag hatte Erdogan die Stichwahl
gegen seinen Herausforderer den
Oppositionsführer gewonnen
ein internationales Abkommen zur
Eindämmung von Plastikmüll das ist das
Ziel der Weg dahin schwierig in Paris
wurde jetzt ein weiterer Schritt getan
und 170 Staaten einigten sich darauf bis
zur nächsten Konferenz im November einen
rechtsverbindlichen Entwurf für ein
Abkommen vorzulegen
umweltverbände kritisieren das als
Minimalkonsens die
plastikverschmutzungen mehreren und
Gewässern nimmt laut Vereinten Nationen
rapide zu
wenn es um das Thema Organspende geht
geben viele Menschen an dass Sie sich
das vorstellen können doch die Zahl der
Organspenden bleibt auf einem niedrigen
Niveau im vergangenen Jahr haben 869
Personen in Deutschland Organe gespendet
teilweise mehrere insgesamt standen
2662 Organe zur Verfügung dem gegenüber
stehen allerdings etwa 8.500 Menschen
die auf ein Organ warten zum Tag der
Organspende berichtet Daniela Sonntag
ihr eigenes Herz wollte nicht mehr
Annett Kraft aus Erfurt lag im
Krankenhaus im Koma als die Nachricht
kam es gibt ein Spenderorgan für sie
seit 14 Jahren lebt sie nun ihr zweites
von einem spendergeschenktes Leben
da bin ich ihm er sie es sehr unendlich
dankbar und wenn dieses
Herz nicht gekommen wäre dann weiß ich
nicht ob ich heute noch da wäre sie
hatte Glück doch viele andere warten
Katharina Roxel ist die
Transplantationsbeauftragte im Wald
Klinikum in Gera beim Thema Organspende
herrsche viel Unwissenheit sagt sie zum
Beispiel das Organe nur bei Menschen
entnommen werden deren Hirn bereits tot
ist ohne Aussicht auf Rettung die
wenigsten wissen dass man wirklich
definitiv verstorben ist zu organspendet
das heißt wir haben zwei unabhängige
Ärzte die den Tod feststellen wer
spenden will muss in Deutschland aktiv
zustimmen zum Beispiel mit dem
Organspendeausweis oder per
Patientenverfügung sinnvoll auch mit der
Familie darüber sprechen doch das
passiert so wenig im Ernstfall Wissen
Angehörige deshalb oft nicht wie sie
sich verhalten sollen
also entscheiden die Angehörigen nach
eigenen Wert Vorstellungen und da haben
wir bis zu 80% Ablehnung dabei könnten
sie leben retten wie das von Annett
Kraft ohne Spenderorgan hätte sie ihre
Enkeltochter wohl nicht mehr
kennengelernt
und jetzt kommen wir zum Sport und da
hast du Rudi ja Formel 1 und vor allem
aber viel Fußball genau da gab es eine
Enttäuschung zunächst die Fußballerinnen
des VfL Wolfsburg haben das Champions
League Finale gegen den FC Barcelona mit
zwei zu drei verloren die Enttäuschung
nach der Niederlage in Eindhoven war
umso größer da das Team von Trainer
Tommy Stroth zu Halbzeit noch mit 2:0
geführt hatte
Wolfsburg Trainer Tommy Stroth und
seinen spanischer Kollege shiral des
haben gerade erst Aufstellung genommen
als Eva pajor in grün Lucy Bros im Ball
wegschnappt und keine Sekunde zögert 1:0
Wolfsburg dritte spielminute.de mit
ihrem achten Treffer in dieser Champions
League Saison
und es kommt noch besser für den VfL 37
Minute
paar joah auf Pop 2 zu 0 Wolfsburg die
Flanke wie gemacht für Deutschlands
beste kopfballspielerin nach dem Wechsel
dann aber ein völlig verwandeltes
Barcelona Hansen auf patri das 2:1 und
kaum ist der Jubel ihres Trainers
vererbt kommen die Favoritinnen auch
schon zum Ausgleich wieder trifft patri
zwei Treffer bin 2 Minuten zum 2 zu 2 20
Minuten später Oberdorf schießt Hendrich
an so kann mariona auf Roll für
querlegen Spiel gedreht Barcelona Sieg
mit drei zu zwei die Minuten nach der
Pause waren entscheiden
wir hatten dann keine Ordnung in ersten
Minuten dann steht's 22 hängen lassen
und was hat er noch nachgelegt und ja so
endet ganz bitte was verheißungsvoll
anfing
ja und das DFB-Pokalfinale der Männer
gleich hier im ZDF Titelverteidiger RB
Leipzig und Eintracht Frankfurt spielen
um den letzten nationalen Titel der
Saison die Frankfurter wollen ihrem
scheidenden Trainer Oliver Glasner einen
glorreichen Abschied bescheren Katrin
Müller-Hohenstein in Berlin
Olympiastadion was erwartest du für ein
Spiel
in dem ordentlich Brisanz steckt RB
Leipzig gegen Eintracht Frankfurt wir
können sagen das ist bislang relativ
ruhig gegangen ist gerade ist ein
böllerhof gegangen aber das war das
einzige was wir bislang gehört haben
sehr ruhig bislang in der Stadt und auch
hier im Stadion und die Mannschaften
sind da wir sehen RB Leipzig den Titel
Verteidiger Pokalsieger 22 und Eintracht
Frankfurt Sieger in der Europa League
natürlich haben sie ihre super Stürmer
mitgebracht Christopher und randalo rein
sportlich wird das sicher ein heißer
Tanz heute Abend die Bilanz total
ausgeglichen zwischen den beiden auf
Augenhöhe und schwer also wird sehr
schwer kann man hier noch einen
Favoriten wir nennen es wird also sicher
ein sehr sehr spannendes Spiel spielen
wir bleiben dran danke
Arminia Bielefeld steht nach einer von
fancavalen überschatten herben
Niederlage beim SVW in Wiesbaden vor dem
Abstieg aus der Zweiten Liga
nachdem der Drittligist in der 82 Minute
zum 4:0 entstand getroffen hatte warfen
Bielefelder Fans Feuerwerkskörper auf
den Rasen und einige Arminia Anhänger
versuchten auf dem Platz zu gelangen
Bielefelds Kapitän Fabian Klos versuchte
die eigenen Fans zu beruhigen aber
Schiedsrichter Benjamin Brand schickte
beide Mannschaften in die Kabinen erst
nach 21 Minuten konnte die Partie
fortgesetzt werden Bielefeld drohen nun
drastische Konsequenzen durch den DFB
Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen hat
sich souverän die Port Position für den
Großen Preis von Spanien gesichert der
Red Bull Pilot setzte sich im Qualifying
von Barcelona vor Carlos science Ferrari
und Lando Norris McLaren durch für den
Niederländer ist es die 24 Paul seine
Karriere und bereits die vierte in
dieser Saison
hasspilot Nico Hülkenberg fuhr auf einen
guten achten Stadtplatz
das war's danke Rudi
sonnige Aussichten für morgen und die
nächsten Tage mit nur kleinen
Einschränkungen komm gleich von Katja
hornerfahrer das heute schon mal mit
Christian Sievers können Sie gegen
22:45 Uhr sehen in der Halbzeitpause des
DFB-Pokalfinales schönen Abend noch
[Musik]
guten Abend Sonnenschein von der Küste
bis zu den alten und südlich der Alpen
besonders nachmittags zum Teil kräftige
Unwetter an diesem Wetter wird sich auch
in den nächsten Tagen wenig ändern heute
Nacht ist es meist klar es gibt etwas
Nebel in Schleswig-Holstein einige
Quellwolken noch in Süddeutschland und
es wird recht kalt die Temperaturen
sinken auf 13 Grad am Oberrhein und bis
drei Grad hier im südlichen Brandenburg
oder auch in der Lausitz und morgen
erwarten uns Höchsttemperaturen zwischen
20 und 27 Grad direkt an der Nordsee
bleibt es bei 15 bis 19 Grad kälter und
das liegt am Aufladen liegen Wind aus
nordwestlichen Richtungen über
Norddeutschland ziehen einige
Wolkenfelder sonst scheint die Sonne
meist strahlend und erst am Nachmittag
drohen dann im Schwarzwald oder direkt
am Alpenrand einzelne Regenschauer oder
kurze Gewitter an diesem Wetter wird
sich auch in den nächsten Tagen nur
wenig ändern bei 16 bis 28 Grad und mit
diesem Foto aufgenommen gestern Mittag
in der Bremer Schweiz wünsche ich Ihnen
jetzt ein schönes Wochenende